Speaker 1: We are in the middle of some pretty
historic times right now, and I don't say that
in the meaningless sort of way, oh, it's
historic. The longest war for the United States
is ending and in some sense, it has ended
in the last few hours. Joe Biden announcing,
as well as Secretary of State Anthony Blinken,
that the United States has flown its final flight
out of Afghanistan where the United States has
been for 20 years. There are now some images
that may become iconic or emblematic in some sense
as we go forward. The Associated Press reporting
that the last troops have exited Afghanistan,
ending America's longest war. And there is this
image this night, vision image of a military
service member provided to the Associated Press
boarding a C17 cargo plane at the airport in Kabul
yesterday, considered the final American service
member to depart Afghanistan. Now, in reality,
there's usually always some caveats, like there's
probably still a few there that are maybe in a
less official capacity or not in uniform or you
never know. You guys understand what I'm saying.
But the point here is Joe Biden is officially
getting the United States out, expected to address
the nation later today. I plan to cover it live
on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook. And the top
line here is that this is a major accomplishment.
The Associated Press writing, The US has completed
its withdrawal from Afghanistan, ending America's
longest war and closing a chapter in military
history likely to be remembered for colossal
failures, unfulfilled promises and a frantic
final exit that cost the lives of more than
one hundred eighty Afghans and 13 U.S. service
members, some barely older than the war. Now,
there are many who want to argue that means that
it was wrong to leave. But it's really important
to understand that if you go in in a harebrained,
ill thought out way, as George W. Bush did,
and you remain for two decades as failures
continue to mount and you fail to achieve
really almost anything other than the
temporary suppression of the Taliban,
why would we assume getting out is going to
go swimmingly? In other words, it doesn't
follow logically if it was a disaster to get
in and it was a disaster while we were there,
is it a reasonable expectation to think that the
exit is going to be ginger snaps and Waterfall's?
Now, I'm not being coy about the fact that
lives were lost in getting out in the same way
that lives were lost while there. It's been some
time since American lives were lost while there.
But Afghan lives have continued to be lost there
and Afghan lives will likely continue to be lost
there after our departure. But the top line
is that this is a major accomplishment in that
the big arc is George W. Bush Gotterson.
It was a disaster. It was a quagmire.
Barack Obama failed to get us out. Donald Trump
failed to get us out, and Joe Biden has gotten
us out. I'm not pretending that the rest is
irrelevant. It's not. It's people's lives. There
are things that could have been done better and
that applies to the entire time we were there and
getting in in the first place. That's not unique
to Joe Biden. But the big picture is, I mean,
in 10 years and 20 years and 30 years, what is
the story of the war in Afghanistan? Obviously,
much of the story remains to be told. It'll depend
on what happens during that period of time. But
the arc is George W. Bush got us in in 2001. We
stayed for 20 years. What the hell were we doing?
And then Joe Biden got us out. That's the big
story. And it is not a story that is being told
in that clear terminology in too many places. Now,
there are some that will write in and say, David,
it's not being told in that clear terminology
because it's not that clear and it's far more
complicated. I'm with you. I'm not pretending
there isn't complexity here, but those are the
big points. A little bit more from this Associated
Press article. Hours before President Joe Biden's
Tuesday deadline for shutting down a final airlift
and thus ending the US war, Air Force transport
planes carried a remaining contingent of
troops from Kabul airport late Monday.
Thousands of troops had spent a harrowing two
weeks protecting the airlift of tens of thousands
of Afghans, Americans and others seeking to escape
a country once again ruled by Taliban militants.
In announcing the completion of the evacuation and
war effort, Gen.. Frank Mackenzie, head of U.S.
Central Command. And said the last planes took
off from Kabul Airport at three twenty nine p.m.
Washington time or one minute before midnight
in Kabul, he said some American citizens likely
numbering in the very low hundreds were left
behind and he believes they will still be able
to leave the country. Secretary of State Anthony
Blinken put the number of Americans left behind at
under two hundred, likely closer to one hundred,
and said the State Department would keep working
to get them out. He praised the military led
evacuation as heroic and said the US diplomatic
presence would shift to Doha, Qatar. Jake
Sullivan. Biden's NSA said Tuesday the mission
to get Americans out of Afghanistan continues.
Biden was set to address the nation on Afghanistan
later Tuesday. We will cover that, as I mentioned,
Biden said in a written statement Monday. Military
commanders unanimously favored ending the airlift,
not extending it. He said he asked Blinken to
coordinate with international partners in holding
the Taliban to their promise of safe passage
for Americans and others who want to leave in
the days ahead. This is a very important thing.
This is the right decision. This was an
unwinnable intervention. And the fact that,
listen, everything we've seen happen in these
two weeks proves that we shouldn't be there. The
Taliban so quickly taking over control, ISIS so
quickly getting in and doing a suicide bombing.
These are not reasons to stay. These are reasons
to leave. And it doesn't mean we don't care about
the people there. But the U.S. simply can't be the
world's policeman in a situation that depends on
our military presence in Afghanistan indefinitely
because of George W. Bush's hairbrained decision
is untenable. And this is correct. I believe
history will bear that out with much tragedy.
In the meantime, there is no denying that
whatsoever. And what I want to talk about next is
what's happening with Joe Biden's approval rating
partially because of Afghanistan, but mostly not